Today, we're going to be speaking with Graham
Wood, who's a journalist, writes for The Atlantic,
also author of the book The Way of the Strangers.
Really glad to have you on.
I'm looking forward to this.
Thanks for having me, David.
So let's talk a little bit about the concept
of a failed state.
There are those who have been attributing
the term failed state to the United States
in the context of the failure to mount a reasonable
response to the coronaviruses pandemic, very
high rate of per capita cases and death others
have been talking about.
The U.S. is a failed state in the context
of Trump's failed leadership in the U.S.,
increasingly being pushed aside on conversations
of climate and so many others.
The idea of a failed state and that we had
a sitting president tried to subvert the will
of the people so brazenly as Donald Trump
tried to keep the White House, even despite
losing to Joe Biden.
What's your sense of how accurate this term
is and how we should think about that?
Well, first of all, I think the term failed
state, as you point out, it's got a diversity
of effects.
It's sometimes just a state that doesn't exist,
sometimes a state that is malevolent, sometimes
a state that doesn't do its job well.
And I think of the of the three probably think
most of of of the last one, but what with
touches of the other ones.
So when I think of other states that have
failed, they're all, of course, horrible humanitarian
disasters.
Somalia probably being the most famous example
in the last few decades.
And I don't see us moving in to that position.
What I do see is enough institutions of government
that have broken down that you could be forgiven
for thinking that that the pressure tests
just exposed huge, huge flaws and shortcomings
in government, and that the most worrying
thing, first of all, is that they exist.
And second of all, if there seems to be no
remedy for them, they don't seem to be getting
any better.
And there is no impetus, certainly with the
current administration, to do what I would
say the necessary work would be to correct
them.
Yeah, a lot of it is failed.
Failure to meet expectations.
Right.
The when we talk about a failed state, it's
not necessarily some of the things you mentioned,
but it's we might have imagined than those
who believe in American exceptionalism might
have imagined.
We would have been one of the best countries
in dealing with the pandemic, a rich country
with so many resources.
So so maybe a lot of it is about the failure
to meet expectations.
Same applies to the Democratic thing, as we
might call it, with regard to the 2020 election.
Just not what people expected.
Yeah.
So I think we can go beyond politics, too.
I mean, the tools that the world has used
to handle the pandemic successfully, where
it's done so successfully, we're largely American
creations.
I mean, American ingenuity created things
like PCR, for example, that has been deployed
at scale with great success in smaller countries,
with fewer resources than we in the United
States have.
So you start seeing the the expectations,
just not not being lived up to.
That's that's, I think, the main thing.
I mean, there's also, though, the fact that
the United States has really never stopped
thinking of itself as in in idealistic terms,
whereas other countries, I think, have been
more cynical about their role in the world.
So, you know, it's not as likely, I think,
to say someone who's from the UK thinking
that the UK is going to be a beacon for hope
that the model of the UK is going to be exported
elsewhere.
As Americans, we we inherit that.
That's it's part of our legacy.
And so we also see ourselves failing to live
up to not just our capacities, but our ideals
that we tell ourselves and then to a large
extent tell other people to you know, I got
a very interesting phone calls in the last
couple of weeks since the election from British
and Belgian viewers, a British and a Belgian
viewer.
And they said, you know, David, and watching
the election take place in the run up to November
3rd and what happened there and after, it's
really weird to see people talking about our
democracy in a campaign like a discussion
of the concept of our democracy in a campaign,
our democracy being at risk or an attack on
democracy, that it was unusual to even see
that discussion and it would be unusual in
places like the U.K. and Belgium and maybe
others.
What's your thought about that?
Yeah, I think to a lot of the world, Americans
look very naive.
I mean, we think that these stories we tell
ourselves are.
True, we don't assume that they're offered
in purely cynical way, and I think that's
a good thing about the United States and it's
something that I actually wish other countries
would would do a bit more of maybe with with
with the with some revisions, as I wish that
we would do some revisions.
You know, there's so much discussion of the
sins of America and the sins actually happened.
So, yeah, we revise our idealism on that basis.
But when a Belgian hears us talk about what
the importance is of American democracy.
If you're a Belgian, that there is no current
strain of Belgian thought that suggests that
maybe the Belgian model is the savior of mankind.
There's definitely a living version of American
exceptionalism that believes exactly that.
So somewhere in the middle is probably the
right place, but it means that the failure
of the United States politically in public
health is all that more all that much more
heartbreaking, I think, to Americans.
What is your sense of where and how unrest
and maybe violence would would develop?
There is speculation.
You know, both sides love to say the other
side is really the violent one.
I believe that when you look at political
violence, the groups that study this have
found that it really is disproportionately
from the right against the left.
But, you know, there's been speculation about
yesterday's milestone, the certification,
the voting of the electors could trigger violence
or January 6th or January 20th, these different
dates.
What what is your sense about what we might
expect and what might really lead to such
violence?
Yeah, I mean, my tendency I'm sort of an empiricist.
I'm a reporter.
I go places and see things and work from there
rather than generalizing trends and then making
predictions from there.
So I'm guessing that going forward, we're
more likely to see things that are totally
unforeseen come up rather than then things
like Republican stab in the back kind of narratives,
for example, being the ones that that that
define the the unrest in the year to come.
So what I'm most worried about is various
unforeseen things that could blossom into
much, much more.
So you take, for example, something like George
Floyd.
There's plenty of examples of police brutality,
of racism, that particular one.
I don't think any of us could have predicted
that it would spark what it did.
And incidents like that will happen more and
more.
It's never been easier to take one incident
that may very well be illustrative or emblematic
or in a good example of a larger trend and
then turn them into something that you could
never have predicted what they would become.
So whenever there is any kind of armed protest,
whenever there is a face off between militias,
they in an American city, which seems to happen
as a matter of course, whenever there's any
kind of public demonstration, you have the
possibility where there will be a gun battle
in America, in an American city, that could
mean dozens of people killed.
I hope that doesn't happen.
But where does that start?
It starts with one gunshot.
And I'm worried that there might be something
that that that begins in that totally unpredictable
and even almost random way.
And the effects of that could be it could
be rippling enormous.
Yeah.
What you're really talking about is the importance
of what Nassim Nicholas Taleb calls black
swans.
Right.
These rare events, which by their nature are
unpredictable risk models don't account for
them.
Risk models that say we are accounting for
really rare events.
Don't Talab kind of elaborate on this further
in his book Fooled by Randomness, it even
takes an important, important role in his
book Antifragile.
These are these are the fundamentally difficult
to to predict events and that's what makes
it so difficult to answer these questions.
Yeah, that's right.
These are spontaneous events and they are
extremely contingent on, you know, if it's
single gunshot that erupts, that that gun
battle that I hypothesized before, then it
could be because that person leaned on his
gun the wrong way.
It could be that he he didn't have a good
breakfast that morning.
That kind of thing is usually what causes
to causes events to be to be kicked into motion.
I mean, if we were to look back a year ago,
there are some things we could have predicted,
some things we couldn't have.
We could have predicted that the president
of the United States would display all the
traits that he's shown and the rest of his
political life.
Those things.
Yes.
But the very fact that we saw this failed
pressure test of of the regulatory and other
apparatus of the United States to the pandemic,
probably not something that anybody had on
the bingo card.
So that kind of thing, I think is much more
likely to define 2021 than anything that that
could be easily foreseen.
I have this idea that I'm curious to get your
thoughts on about there are competing forces
that sort of make it less likely that you
will see mass rallies, huge protests in the
United States to the level that they sort
of start shutting down aspects of the economy
or cities or whatever the.
So maybe and it's on the one hand, you have
the combination of ready access to credit
and cheap stuff from China and other countries,
which keeps a lot of people just comfortable
enough not to go out and protest because they'd
rather stay home and watch the game, so to
speak.
And this is not to diminish civic activism.
It's not to pretend that everybody's in a
comfortable position.
But there's there's a swath of the population
that may be in a different economy without
ready access to cheap, cheap stuff from China
and without ready access to credit with which
to buy that stuff might be less comfortable
and thus more eager to go out and protest.
Now, on the other hand, you have this kind
of forced precarity, people who recognize,
wait, if I take a day off to go protest, I
could lose my job or at least not get paid
that day.
And then my health insurance is in question
and then I don't know if I have food for my
kids.
And so that this incentivizes going out to
protest.
What do you think of that as a systemic analysis
that maybe so.
I mean, the Russian Revolution famously might
not have happened if the weather hadn't permitted
certain, you know, crossing of the rivers
and by by large groups of people.
So it's not it's not impossible that there
would be would be things like that that would
be equally determinative of whether people
are willing to go out and and be the political
en mass.
There's also, though, again, the relationship,
for example, between the protests that happened
this summer and the pandemic, I think is still
misunderstood, underexploited.
They seem in some ways to have nothing to
do with each other, police violence is something
that's happened for a very long time.
The pandemic was it was almost like a short
break that people took from the pandemic to
deal with this urgent matter.
Now, I think there's probably more to it than
that.
The effects on mass psychology, individual
psychology of being pent up, of being prevented
from seeing the faces of other human beings
is immense.
And once that stops, I think a lot of things
will actually change.
They might not change in predictable ways,
but things like the politics of mass gatherings,
that could be one of the things that that.
Turns out to change a lot as a result of a
coming of save vaccine, in terms of the psychological,
I've been thinking a lot about post covid
I think that even when mathematically things
go back to what they were before, where during
flu season, you have a higher risk of catching
the flu.
And it's less deadly than coronavirus, but
it's the same as before coronavirus.
I think that there will be risks that were
always there that people weren't maybe thinking
of.
And you may see folks, particularly in certain
risk categories, who just during flu season
might want to wear a mask or might stay home,
or I think there's going to be sort of a realignment
as a flexible as much as humans return to
the mean and go back to the way things were.
I think that at least for four years, they're
going to be aspects of this with us.
Yeah, I mean, there's some just factual knowledge
that that we have that either didn't know
before or we didn't care about before, like
the fact that that, you know, during flu season
you can possibly save thousands and thousands
of lives by doing something like wearing a
mask.
Every Japanese person do that.
Almost no Americans do that.
So that knowledge is with us for good.
What I'm thinking of more, ah, is I'm thinking
more about different types of psychological
effects.
I mean, I've had a strange pandemic in that
I was I was isolated as we were all told to
be for four months at a time.
I'm glad I did that.
And then I've gone out and I've reported to
so and I've moved from country to country
to I've been traveling more than most people
this year and have seen how the pandemic looks
from from place to place.
And I would not have guessed from my position
of solitude in those first months how different
the feeling in psychology was.
Mass psychology was of going out and experiencing
places where the pandemic hadn't hit as hard.
So I think we can be lulled into thinking
that that that nothing deeply has changed
about how we're looking at the world because
it changes slowly.
And then once there is the great pandemic
jailbreak, because the curve has been broken
or the vaccine has been distributed.
And I think what will emerge and we will discover
with great surprise how different the world
has become while we were locked away.
That's that's what I'm actually mostly looking
forward to.
I think the world will be a we'll discover
that the world suddenly improves once we are
able to go out.
But the fact of change, I have little doubt
about massive change.
Yes, absolutely.
I absolutely agree.
We've been speaking with Graham Wood, a journalist
who writes for The Atlantic and is also author
of the book The Way of the Strangers.
So appreciate your time today, Graham.
It was a pleasure.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.